I imagine you guys wanna see a magic
trick before this video gets kicked off
our pick a number between one and ten
don't tell me what it is or anything
that number seven the odds are one in
ten that I blew your mind just now
that's magic now you see me so now you
see me is the story of for magicians
they're played by Woody Harrelson jesse
eisenberg isla fisher and dave franco
they'll get brought together in the
beginning of the movie the next thing
you know it's a year later and then the
scenarios you see in the trailer start
happening starting out with they rob a
bank with magic Mark Ruffalo's the FBI
agent he's trying to figure out how they
did it and he's tracking him down he's
trying to remain one step ahead of them
but they're magicians so they're really
smart and they think [ __ ] through us we
have our movie that's pretty
entertaining edited time with this movie
because the crew really worked these
guys had great chemistry together they
worked well together they they were a
good ensemble we like the Ninja Turtles
of magic then you have Morgan Freeman
and Michael Caine in the mix Mark
Ruffalo is good in the movie too I've
given Mark Ruffalo some [ __ ] in my time
after the Avengers though never again
the dude is the best Bruce Banner slash
Hulk that's ever existed in history of
life he stole all of his scenes in the
Avengers that ain't nothing and he was
cool in this movie too and when you're
gonna stand out when you're in a movie
with Isla Fisher that is also impressive
now you see me is like national treasure
with magic which I had a good time with
national treasure I'd saw it once when
it came out in theaters but I remember
liking it it's real magic in the mix
though it automatically makes something
pretty cool if they can pull it off well
for the most part they do if you're one
of those people is like by the end of
this movie everything has to logically
make sense in order for me to like it
you're probably not gonna like it
because it's not gonna happen you're not
gonna walk out of this movie going that
was absolutely cool and perfectly
plausible it's realistic it could
totally happen because it couldn't is
there's no way Brainiac from the
Superman comics couldn't think enough
steps ahead to make the premise of this
movie actually happened in real life but
I was still able to sit there and enjoy
the movie for what it was found me and
honest I didn't like the end I thought
the end was just one of those convenient
things like yeah here here's the end I
just don't think the ending makes sense
for what I saw for the past two hours
for some people that'll be enough to
bring the movie down to go noot not a
good movie for me really wasn't
hey side note you know what is
completely perfect in the movie isla
Fisher I really mean that - I would
shred my single bachelor life to settle
down with and marry Isla Fisher
listen Sacha Baron Cohen has made that
impossible for me Here I am single if it
is I am being serious you know what
classy
because I respect her as a woman nice
tell me that's not magic so the movie
had a cool ensemble the cast worked
really well together it was a cool heist
type movie with magicians and magic
thrown into it but you know that's not a
bad gimmick for a heist movie we can
call it a hi this kind of a heist movie
we'll call it a magic movie where the
magician's have kind of an illegal ish
goal it's not oh she's 11 or the Italian
job but I walked out of the movie
thinking now you see me is a good time
no alcohol required just give some
magician some exposure who's your
favorite magician out there could be a
nobody he could be on YouTube ever they
might be comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more